The Joe Rogan Experience the piss is
just dirty water
if you're drinking water you're drinking
dinosaur piss I love it do you know that
like all water on Earth at one point in
time if you just think statistically the
hundreds of millions of years of
dinosaurs were around
all that water at some point in time was
filtered out of a dinosaur's dick
that sounds insane and not true I think
it's true I don't think that's true
let's see
yeah well how would you phrase that
every glass of water you drink
originally was in dinosaur urine
dinosaurs drink the same water as us or
originally was dinosaur urine I wanted
to be urine I wanted to be real specific
all the water you drink came from
dinosaur urine just be ridiculous uh
um well the way I asked it her hair
someone did ask the question you're
asking right are you you are yeah you
are drinking dinosaur pee every day
here's why oh
yeah there you go yeah you are drinking
dinosaur pee every day here's why from
Tech times
the average American drinks four cups of
water every day according to US
Department of Agriculture this is far
short of the recommended eight glasses
blah blah blah whether it's tap filtered
bottled sparkling or sourced from the
Himalayan glaciers and sparkled with
Gold Dust you are actually drinking the
liquid waste of an ancient Beast says a
science-centric YouTube channel curious
minds a video explaining this Theory
says that every small percentage of all
the water in the world is available for
drinking purposes but it's still a huge
amount of water to provide for the needs
of every human being that's ever walked
in the surface of the Earth for the last
two hundred thousand years every year
around 121 000 cubic miles of water
about the equivalent of 42 Lake
superiors falls down on Earth constantly
flows through the rivers lakes ground
reservoirs and everywhere else it passes
through including inside the guts of
people and the animals that drink it so
what do dinosaurs have to do with all
this unlike humans who have been on
Earth for a tiny fraction of the 186
million years that dinosaurs ruled the
planet
the the beasts were here far longer than
we have ever been in that long span of
time it's very likely the dinosaurs have
drunk all the water available back then
and then all the water available now is
simply water that has passed through a
dinosaur's kidneys making its way
through the never-ending water cycle
that's crazy that dinosaurs were around
for 186 million years yeah if you told
me they were around for 100 years I
would have believed it I know nothing
about dinosaurs yeah they're around
forever if it wasn't for a rock they'd
still be around that's crazy yeah and
then we get to drink their pissed that's
what's interesting about life on other
planets like if something like the
dinosaurs does exist it takes something
like the Yucatan impact to to kill them
and then the little scrambly little
rodents and [__] eventually evolved to
become humans but if that doesn't happen
forever and ever and ever it's just
dinosaurs [__] things up and no one
ever builds a house no one ever gets a
Tesla just pissing yeah every time you
go outside Raptors tear you apart
there's you live in like tiny caves and
they try to find you in there and they
drag your kids out
yeah they send a little Raptor in there
and they grab your kid by the feet you
crawl into little tunnels and holes as
they nip at you and try to claw away at
the Rocks to get to you you never
develop tools yeah you never develop
anything you barely stay alive you
probably go extinct somehow that
submarine thing sounds less worse than
that
if you lived in that era I think
everything ate everything probably and
the only way you didn't get eaten if you
were like a Stegosaurus where you're
just covered in armor
to keep things from eating you I mean
imagine like what kind of [__] hard
life you have to be living in to develop
the kind of skin the stegosaurus has
just armor everywhere you are like a
Triceratops yeah everywhere your armor
is to keep you from getting consumed
you see yeah
so yeah that's the bright side of the
impact I'm drinking dinosaur pets yeah
we're drinking dinosaur piss and that's
the the bright side of Apocalypse caused
by an asteroid impact
not that bad it's pretty good it's way
better than dinosaurs still being being
around and it's way better than Donkey
Kong yes
not that I know but I assume this is
better my coffee is dinosaur pissed yeah